moi et maintenant speed parade sherazade
ouais si louis et sa copine corinne ex
téléphone etc bertignac et les visiteurs
les axes ont-ils un futur où sont ils
condamnés à jouer les doublures
c'est ce qu'on va voir mon garçon tu
sais nous le top 5 ans nous intéresse
pas vraiment et ben si réussie par les
visiteurs bonsoir voila pour se marrer
on est là pour faire la promo je veux
tout nouvel album s'appelle rocks alors
le premier c'était en quelle année 86 87
nous est foutue quoi depuis trois ans
qu'est ce qui aurait été tournée
ouais pas mal pourquoi en france en
finlande en russie
on a préparé deux les nouvelles chansons
on a cherché les membres de notre groupe
ça y est on a donné les noms alors ils
étaient faits à memphis avec un mec
super jim games soudure qui s'est quand
même parce que c'est un vieux de la
vieille qui a commencé à 17 ans comme
assistant sur otis redding en suède à
travailler avec mes villes brothers et
ensuite quand il a été assez grands pour
faire ça tout seul il nous a fait des
révocable santana souris lewis dés gens
comme ça il a écouté notre cas cette île
à 10,1 me plaît beaucoup mais en anglais
et j'habite à memphis voulez-vous venir
me rejoindre
nous avons dit oui louis à c'est très
content d'en placer une solidarité
masculine quand même si tu devais me
levant cet album si tu avais une minute
ils ont tu me lis avec moi ces marchands
de disques et je serai le client mais
moi je te dirais tu connais pas ouais tu
ne montes ne vous connais pas tu
appelles rocks et les moniteurs
ce n'est pas ça vous ne pourrez pas
faire d'émission de t